ils ont repris les cours le 18 mai
dernier
ces apprentis en 2e année de ces apps et
maintenance motocycles font partie des
élèves de l'institut national du cycle
et du motocycle à avoir repris leur
formation en présentiel au déconfinement
ils sont une quarantaine de jeunes de
l'établissement sur la centaine
accueilli habituellement qu'on a fait le
choix en fait de prioriser les publics
qui doivent passer leur certification
leur diplôme cette année parce qu'en
effet il ya eu quand même du retard sur
les cours même si on a fait
l'enseignement à distance et parce qu'il
ya un gros enjeu de certification et
d'obtention du diplôme achats de douze
mille masques gel hydroalcoolique
utilisation de gand et suppression des
espaces collectifs des heures de rang
très différente des horaires de pause
avec un quart d'heure de décalage un
plan pensé depuis mi avril pour faire
respecter les gestes barrière après deux
mois de cours à distance en
visioconférence même quand on fait des
démonstrations en visio c'est pas eux
qui pratiquent ces peuples qui
manipulent les outils ni les pièces du
coup il ya forcément un peu de pertes
niveau pratique on a essayé d'adapter le
programme en fait deux
faire en sorte qu'on puisse leur
apporter le plus de connaissances
possibles dans le laps de temps du co
qui a été réduit donc ils ont un peu
plus d'heure d'ateliers il faut enfin en
sorte d'avoir des programmes peut-être
un peu plus chargé mais d'être plus à
l'écouté en fait de leurs attentes et de
leurs demandes
par exemple sur une semaine le lundi le
mardi et le jeudi peuvent être consacrés
aux enseignements généraux puis des
cours en ateliers sont prévus le
mercredi et le vendredi
un retour au sein de l'établissement
bien accueillis par les élèves le fait
d'écouter son professeur parler à
distance même voir des schémas et ça ça
nous permet quand même pas de pratiques
et donc ouais c'est compliqué et il ya
juste avec l'école ça change un petit
peu avant ces trois jours d'école avec
après on va les deux derniers jours au
travail là maintenant on fait des
semaines complètes pour rattraper un
petit peu leur part une à deux semaines
de cours ont été rajoutés pour compenser
la période du confinement
la formation devrait se terminer le 10
juillet prochain